his football morning in america column
is always must-read material
today in particular um he's kind enough
to call in even though he's uh he's
supposed to be tapping out he's supposed
to be on vacation he said yes to uh the
invitation to come here and i always
appreciate that
the old time great peter king how are
you sir
hi rich how are you i'm doing better for
talking to you
so uh walk me through
walk everyone through how that video
that roger goodell posted
came to be peter
well roger goodell like everyone in the
league office
knew that there were players who were
working with
an nfl employee a 27 year old nfl social
media producer
who unhappy with the league's response
and the unwillingness for the league to
uh
on the record in words condemn racism
and say black lives matter
this 27 year old white male
living in a shoe box of an apartment in
mar vista which is probably not far from
you
uh basically reached out to
uh mike thomas of the saints on
instagram he sent him a direct message
and said hey
uh i'm disappointed with our response
with this this is what i do
love to help you reach out if you can
and 23 minutes later
michael thomas reached out to him and
said yeah you know we need a vehicle we
have the
opinions uh and we also have
the channels we have the the social
media
outlet to make this go wide
and so this video was made in a 24-hour
period
i think everybody who is listening to
this most most everybody
has seen it with the 20 nfl players on
it
just basically not i
i'd say asking nicely but forcefully
to roger goodell in the nfl listen
to us and
uh you know you have to do the following
and the next morning at 10 o'clock roger
goodell kicked off
his virtual daily meeting with his
executive vice presidents
and he kicked that off by saying i'm
going to make a video today
and then uh the rest of that day was
basically made up with uh the script
uh what is what he's going to say how
he's going to say it
and he pretty much did almost exactly
what the players asked him to do yeah
so i thought it was i thought it was
kind of a watershed moment now where it
goes from here
is i write nobody knows he's got 32
bosses
and this might be nice for roger goodell
to say and think but is he going to get
buy-in from the owners in the nfl well i
guess what what would buy-in look like
peter
i don't know that no one knows i mean
does it mean that
you can protest during the national
anthem doing anything you want maybe
does it mean that we are going to get
together with players and make some sort
of deal
somehow some way we will do something
if you will stand for the anthem at some
sort of attempt
of attention i don't know it's just so
early in the process
feelings are so raw opening day is three
months from
from wednesday so there's plenty of time
for people to just settle down
uh and think about this and think about
what
a solution and next steps entail
well what about letting the players
figure that out and then the league's
basically saying gotcha and uh and then
and give them
to give them the platform that that that
if you're listening
well players come up with it and then
just in terms of kneeling on the anthem
i mean you want to talk about the
realities of 2020
um it's been a long while since uh
broadcasts
uh showed the national anthem to a
country and if there's no fans in the
stands
you know right it's it it may not
have the same effectiveness of calling
attention to what
needs to have attention called to it or
rich
right you know the networks do show
occasionally they do show the national
anthem
um you know there are games during the
year certainly
at the super bowl uh and other i i i
i can't tell you maybe there's ten games
during the year that for one reason or
another
they show the national anthem so uh
you're right they don't often show the
national anthem but
it's not like if a tree falls in the
forest and no one is there it didn't
happen or whatever that cliche is
right the point is that uh
you know people whether they kneel
whatever sort of
kind of demonstration or defiant act
they do during the anthem
people are going to learn about it and
find out about it so whether or not it's
on national tv i don't think is the most
important thing
peter king football night in america nbc
sports here on the rich eisen show
so um now that it's filtering into
uh there's 32 uh members of the national
football league
who who can essentially make what
what this is uh seems to be moving
in the in a seismic direction uh
actually codify this thing what might be
a next step
from what you're hearing peter i think
there are some players
that want um
and this is going to be this is i'm
probably overstating this
who want some sort of satisfaction on
colin kaepernick
you know they're you know michael thomas
uh
the safety for the houston texans
is the uh who's outspoken and very
involved
in social issues you know on the level
of
of a malcolm jenkins and chris long
he very much thinks that the nfl has to
make amends with colin kaepernick
however this is going to be done
in my opinion i think
i'm not saying that this ends up with
colin kaepernick being in a uniform and
helmet on opening day
i i don't know what it means but i think
that there needs to be uh some paris
peace talks between
uh league executives and colin
kaepernick yeah
behind the scenes where nobody knows
about it i mean
you thought that it's like i said you
know rich like i i wrote in my column
today about drew brees
um you know i even though he's done an
incredible amount for the state of
louisiana and city of new orleans over
the last 15 years
in my opinion just my opinion if i were
him
i would do something very significant
for the black community of new orleans
like this year and
or the black community of louisiana uh
maybe involving education whatever it
would be
but i do something without cameras being
there
i would just do it because you you had
it in your heart that
you really uh did want to
make amends if indeed that's that's what
he wants to do but
i'm saying it's about the same thing
with with kaepernick i just think that
there is this still this open sore
and without uh without putting sav on it
and putting a bandage on it
i still think that a lot of this stuff
is not going to go away well i mean in
just uh
before we we move on to the actual
playing of the season and the health
protocols that were issued this morning
about
um all 32 teams needing to follow when
players are are back in the facility
peter king here on the rich eisen show
i mean what happened last year where
kaepernick was receiving a tryout
coming out of the blue it was done you
know where nobody saw it coming
at least most of us in who follow the
nfl and cover it and didn't see that
coming
it was put on a ridiculously short
time frame um that spurred
nothing but dis uh mistrust from
kaepernick's side
of things to the point where kaepernick
switched up the location of the workout
last minute which pissed off so many
members of the
of the uh uh talent evaluation community
some of them did go to his workout the
question and what a whole
holy heck of a mess that whole thing
turned out to be
how how can there be some form of trust
you know where
you said some sort of paris basic courts
but
maybe the video that the commissioner
said would be the first step and
[Music]
and and then he would have it would have
to be i think that
he wants rich i think whatever happens
it has to be done
privately at least at first there's no
good way to do this by roger goodell
standing up to announce
i am going to have coffee with colin
kaepernick right next tuesday at
starbucks in midtown
i mean you know it's he's got to reach
out in my opinion
to both him and his people and to say
can we have a conversation off the
record conversation or whatever it would
be
can we just have a conversation you know
of course everything that has happened
is spawned mistrust between both sides
we all know that
so and maybe there's nothing that can be
done all i know
is that i think that at least in my
opinion that's where step one needs to
be
because there are so many players in
this league right now
who are still hot that colin kaepernick
got frozen out of a job four years ago
peter king here on the rich eisen show
football night in america's peter king
so it sure looks like this season's
going to go down peter right
i mean it looks like um you know coaches
are back in facilities now with the
exception of i believe only the 49ers um
that uh that the health protocols were
put out
they were they're very stringent but
it's nothing that can't be
um that cannot be done and
testing will be there i'm hearing about
you know n95 material
put over face masks to help uh mask
players and
practice social distancing despite being
literally next to each other on top of
each other like
this looks like it's a go peter to me
well it is but again you knew
basically rich you knew that the nfl was
going to come up with an
exhaustive extremely thorough plan you
knew that
they're too smart not to but that
doesn't mean
that when john doe leaves x facility
and goes out and has two beers on a
thursday night
you know at a bar that he's not smashed
in with 64 people in a small area
he's going to be told by the infection
control officer
in every team all these guys are going
to be told don't
do this and i think the vast majority
and who knows maybe 100 percent
will not do it but i think it's
unrealistic to
when the rest of the human race is
allowed to go out and socialize
by and by the fall i'm sure that most
places in the united states
will be wide open so that's the whole
thing i
i have an item in my column this week
you know talking to alan sills and he
said you cannot build
a complete impenetrable bubble around
teams
and so you know the nfl is going to do
everything within its power
but that doesn't mean that some saturday
morning
when uh 70 players on the active
and practice squads and and injured
reserve when all those people are tested
it doesn't mean that there aren't going
to be two or three who come up positive
and we hope of course that nobody comes
up positive
and it could well be that nobody will
come up positive but
you know i think the nfl also has to be
prepared
for a worst case scenario what happens
if three or four guys on the same team
test positive what are you going to do
and what is the team that's supposed to
play him that week going to do
you know are you supposed to say well
these four guys are going to be
quarantined for two weeks
but they haven't really run into anybody
in the last few days so
the rest of the team is okay that's
unrealistic
so that is that sort of nuclear option
is going to be very weird
if it comes into play this season and
i'm i have no idea
as of right now if the nfl knows what
it's going to do about that it surely
isn't saying
peter king here on the rich eisen show
dak doesn't get done until the last
second in july yay or nay
that i that's probably right i i would
think
um and if it doesn't get done he'll just
show up making whatever it is 31 or 32
million
that's kind of crazy peter i mean it
right i mean
well it's crazy it's crazy that it got
to this point
for a smart a businessman as jerry jones
knows it's amazing is
it's amazing that he and stephen jones
at the beginning of this
did not understand and did not take
seriously enough
that uh dak prescott and his hardline
agent
uh we're not going to do a team friendly
deal and
you never ever ever
profit when negotiating a quarterback
contract
when you wait never doesn't happen
name the last team that waited
joe flacco the baltimore ravens he raked
the ravens over the coals now he won a
super bowl
but you know he ended up killing the
baltimore ravens with that contract
it never helps the team to wait and yet
the cowboys waited
certainly i don't mean to say they get
what they deserve but they get what they
deserve nice
you know what i mean i guess again peter
i mean um
mahomes and or watson they're they're
they're already on the clock i mean
yeah so why wouldn't you want to get
your guy don't worry about those two if
i was
if i was counting there if i was uh
brett beach and town mcnair and
you know and bill o'brien and jack
easterbee and the guys with the texans
i'd be getting that contract done before
training camp
if it all humanly possible because the
only thing that's going to happen by
waiting
is his value is going to go up because
other quarterbacks are going to sign
so and you know maybe that's the way
those guys will feel too
i mean there's no reason for me to to
sign even if this thing blows today's
contracts out of the water you know well
and just uh i guess to bring it all full
circles i'm sure you heard what i was
saying when i was introducing you could
you imagine
what this would be like in the nfl if
the nfl and the nflpa did not
have their collective bargaining
agreement hammered out just before
yeah everything came to a halt you're
seeing what's going on with baseball
right now that would
that this would be a major part of the
conversation right now trying to get
ready for
the amazing thing is rich when you think
about it is that an
average an average of 30
players in every locker room
voted no on that contract an average of
30 players
think about that wow 33 voted yes 30
voted no
that's how close this was and you know
look if
if players didn't vote for it then you
know hey they
i'm sure they would regret it right now
and i think
i think reason prevailed it's like the
only time i think
it that i ever remember a sports labor
agreement
where the director of the players
association was urging his players
to do this deal and
a lot of the player leaders were saying
no don't do the deal don't do the deal
it was that was crazy but you're
absolutely right
players are certainly fortunate in my
opinion anyway that
that they got the deal done peter thanks
for the time enjoy your time
down uh always appreciate the calls to
this show always
i really appreciate it rich thank you so
much you got it that's peter king at
peter underscore king
i must follow